make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
everything the light touches is our
kingdom Simba but what about that over
there dad that's the hood son you must
never go there what's going on guys this
is Rob I just woke up a little bit ago
so I still got that uh that very deep
part of my voice that people really seem
to enjoy anyway so we are covering Thor
Thor fighting his granddad and it's
actually amazing and then it's actually
hilarious at the same time right so a
couple things to understand first and
foremost ah this is kind of like the
fruition of a plan that Loki had for
some time right the idea that Loki had
always been looking for a way to get for
out of Asgard and this really kind of
comes hot off the heels of J michael
Straczynski throne or actually really is
it at the tail end of sturgeon skis run
of course we cover the first issue where
Thor had basically rebuilt Asgard and
earth I guess the first arc where story
hit rebuilt Asgard Loki came back as a
Czech different things like that but
this was basically the planet Loki had
to essentially find a way to bring Bohr
into the modern era now of course Bohr
is the father of Odin right so that's
really where all this kind of comes out
I think eyes are probably heard of the
story I don't think I've ever actually
had a chance to check it out it's pretty
cool ah but this also takes place during
Dark Reign so a little bit of
explanation here Dark Reign was the it
was a really a story arc right it wasn't
like Civil War right where you sit down
you read Marvel Civil War and it's like
Civil War part 1 2 3 4 all the way up
through 7 it wasn't really like that
Dark Reign was a rebranding initiative
so it was basically an event that had
taken place whereby Norman Osborn had
basically become director of shield he
came in the aftermath of Secret Invasion
but Norman Osborn became director of
shield he disbanded shield and then
replace it with hammer and that
immediately tried to like conquer the
United States and and really the world
in a lot of different ways Dark Reign
was all of that right where things were
just really really dark for all the
superheroes and so what you ended up
getting here was basically a whole bunch
of tie-ins whether the stories were more
or less kind of shifted and changed it
was very reminiscent of the old nineteen
nineties Age of Apocalypse we didn't
really have a Jew apocalypse part 1 2 3
4 or whatever
everything was just shifted for six
months now the difference is that with
Age of Apocalypse it was a total
distortion and warping of reality with
this one it's just a bad thing happen in
the other is kind of how it all plays
out but Loki was brought in as part of
the Cabal of Norman Osborn his inner
circle of bad guys more or less
dr. doom I think it was Emma Frost and
maybe a couple of people deliver I don't
really remember who they are not what
Loki had done was essentially go to the
Past and more or less take out Bohr kind
of have his soul left in the snow and
then in turn in the modern era
reconstituted right so basically extract
him out or at least extract his spirit
and reconstitute his physical form in
the modern age and as soon as that
happens things pop off and that's where
it gets cool right because one of the
things to understand is that Bohr
represents the Asgardians of old and
it's kind of a funny thing how Aden
would compare to Bohr in terms of like
Odin with the odinforce at its full
power and Bohr you know with you know
Bohr at full strength I don't entirely
know I would say Owen would probably win
with the full totality of the odinforce
but Bohr represents the old line of ask
audience right they were exceedingly
strong exceedingly capable they were
wildly powerful they weren't just like
you know how four is now whether were
just really strong with a really cool
weapon it was intense it was kind of
nuts and so when war comes back he's
immediately he immediately has an
enchantment bestowed on him by uh by
Loki which basically distorts his
perception of the world and so
everything he sees is twisted and evil
right it's not really the way that
things are and this is designed to send
him on a warpath is really what it's
designed for
right now the funny thing about this and
we'll see why this matters so much here
at you know once we get to the end but
he immediately goes on a warpath
looking for Odin now this is before the
return of Odin right so if you guys
recall during dan Jergens run on fort
odin had died at the hands of Surtur dan
Jergens run concluded and then it went
into a handful of story arcs here and
there by miscellaneous writers and then
it went into the the thor ragnarok story
where Thor died and then came back and
then we picked up with screws and skis
run so at this moment
Odin is not returned Odin is basically
dead Marvel ended up shifting that up he
was basically locked in eternal battle
with Serdar for he was supposed to be
for all time and somehow brought out on
the rough town my head it was hand wavy
it's more or less what it was but
essentially like Bohr comes out he sees
like all these people who look like
demons he sees a giant truck and he's
like monstrous priest and then he goes
to smash it and this is where where
Loki's kind of waiting to see what all
is playing out here like what all is
going on Loki kind of leaves a scenario
Jane Foster is currently around there
and ends up calling Donald Blake now
this is one of the things that J michael
Straczynski did in the face of of
launching his Thor run was to return
to the old-school method of Donald Blake
right so fully guys who are familiar
with this and you haven't really been
reading Thor for any real measure of
time Donald Blake was like the alter ego
of four backward board was first created
alter egos were still a very very
popular thing right Batman Bruce Wayne
Clark Kent Superman it was still a very
popular concept and so in order to kind
of make Thor tangible right and to give
him something else to do besides
constantly writing magical stories what
Marvel did is they basically said that
Thor was a singular entity unto himself
at one point in time and then the result
here is that because he was so full of
arrogance and so full of hubris that
Odin had basically created the body of
of Donald Blake and then put force
essence inside of it and then wiped his
mind of who he was so we wouldn't know
that he was an ass guardian and then put
him on earth and he spent most of his
life just being Donald Blake until one
day aliens show up he's with Jane Foster
he goes running into a cave he finds a
stick in his frustration he hits it on
the ground the stick turns into the
hammer and the hammer the hammer turns
Donald Blake into Thor and it was just
that way forever and ever and ever and
ever for decades it was that way if he
lost his hammer for 60 seconds he would
turn back into Donald Blake and it was a
way to kind of create a weakness right
to make Thor tangible otherwise he'd be
talking about this nigh indestructible
God running around with a hammer just
crushing every enemy enemy that he that
he went up against and so because of
that eventually the time came when
Marvel got rid of the whole hammer and
it was it was a staged process right not
remember Lee the hammer effect but I
guess Thor League is losing his hammer
for 60 seconds that went away the idea
of Donald Blake that went away he was a
stage process that took place over the
course of five to ten years and
basically we were left with the Thor
that you're familiar with were just
Odin's son and his hammer and he's on
the Avengers and doing his thing and
that's basically it uh when Straczynski
took over really the the kind of
direction of Marvel at the time under
Joe Quesada was we turned things back to
the way they were before and so that's
what you ended up getting with Donald
Blake you got his return and and again
that's why you see this play out the way
that it does when Jane Foster says you
know there's something going on down
here you should have where you should
get our mutual friend down here and so
the result is that Donald Blake goes up
to a rooftop he takes his walking stick
smash it on the ground and he turns into
Thor that's why that happens is because
it's a return to familiarity to the way
things used to be right but this leaves
Thor basically directly down coming
across board now Thor does not know who
bore his right Thor has never met or
he's never seen his face he doesn't know
that this is his grandfather more
and remember this is during the era
where by four is still trying to find
the spirit of sets right he's still
trying to figure out who she it or find
where her essence is right because if
you guys recall after the events of
Ragnarok in the destruction of Asgard
all the Asgardians were reborn in
physical form and though in the bodies
of mortals and Thor spent a most of the
time of seers and skis run traveling
around trying to figure out where they
were and then freeing them kind of
restoring Asgard and in that way and so
in his mind when he hears about this
going on he immediately thinks it's a
lost Asgardian he immediately thinks
it's one of the Asgardians from the
events of Ragnarok who's basically been
lost and he's trying to find a way to
bring him back but given the fact that
he's got a sort of twisted perception
because of the spell of Loki immediately
war looks at if Thor in sees him as like
a monster why she's him is like a beast
and believes that he alongside others
are the reason why Onan is going right
because at this point boy reaches out
and senses the fact that across the
multiverse the universe there is no own
right in none of the nine realms Odin
does not exist and so because that he
realizes Odin is dead and immediately
comes to the belief that Thor is the one
who did it right and it's kind of crazy
because what you end up having is kind
of like you know Bohr going to attack
Thor Thor and turn blocking the shot
with his hammer and then Bohr overpowers
him anyway and just sends him flying and
that's what we're talking about here
that's the kind of strength that we're
dealing with you we're literally dealing
with like Bohr just kind of jumping
around and just absolutely demolishing
for it and that's what's so crazy about
it is for the most part Thor is totally
overwhelmed here in this battle that
he's facing he's completely of a lump
one because he's kind of holding back to
a degree right as his due his desire is
really more to slow down and to stop not
to kill whereas this guy is hiring to
kill right Bohr is desiring to it to
kill for it
and so in response Thor is like okay
well this guy can take it let's throw my
hammer at him and let's basically try to
stop them and then Bohr reaches up and
catches it stops the hammer dead in its
tracks and then catches it and this is
not supposed to happen and what this
does is appointed the idea that the
worthiness enchantment does not apply to
Bohr or he's powerful enough to overcome
the worthiness enchantment right that it
doesn't really matter to him now that's
one of the things to understand the
enchantment is only really as powerful
as Odin himself right so if a beam comes
along who's more powerful than Odin then
they should be able to lift the hammer
right like a being who can alter reality
for example somebody like the molecule
man can basically alter reality so even
it's not really you know worthy of
wielding the hammer he could alter the
molecular structure of the hammer
so that like it's lighter right or
somebody like graviton can make the
hammer lighter so that he can use it
himself at least speaking how to make
those assumptions but that's kind of how
that worked right there's different ways
to sort of loophole your way into being
able to lift the hammer with borer it's
not explicitly stated now the reason why
this matters is because what this does
is it establishes how Bohr really exists
within the main Marvel Universe that
despite the fact that that Thor does
have the odinforce which of course was
passed down to him following the death
of Odin that even with that power Bohr
is still able to overcome the owner so
what we're talking about here is a guy
who is more powerful to note that's
really what we're looking at here and
that's what that's that's really kind of
the the transitive property sort of
situation you're looking at or at least
you're using when you're looking at
these two characters right that's what
makes this so interesting and makes it
so cool is because Thor is almost never
faced a foe like this somebody's so
astronomically powerful the only time
that I would say Thor has ever faced an
enemy like this before are the various
times where he's faced Surtur the time
worried at times where he's faced
man-god back during the muttering like
the 80s back there like old school for
stories that kind of a thing right but
since then oh really he hasn't really
faced a foe like this and that's what
makes Bohr so incredibly dangerous is
Bors is fighting to kill and that's
basically it right it ends up coming
down to kind of like a hand-to-hand
conflict but literally Thor fighting
with every ounce of the odinforce he has
using everything at his disposal is
still fighting for his life against Bork
and so that's when he finally makes the
call and he simply says Avengers
Assemble and calls all the Avengers
together and that's when that's what we
really kind of pick up on the notion of
Dark Reign that when all these Avengers
are basically summoned here that they're
not the Avengers that that Thor is
familiar with right that the Avengers of
Thor's familiar with they're all Secret
Avengers now right they're all under
they're all basically underground what
he's dealing with here are the Dark
Avengers right so I lose you guys who
were who were unfamiliar with this
during Dark Reign what you got were dark
versions of superhero team tried some
basically villains taking the place of
stupid euros in the Marvel Universe
right so when it came to the the Dark
Avengers for example you had a
bull's-eye who replaced Hawkeye right
you had a kid who replaced Wolverine
you had Norman Osborn who was really the
iron patriot but replaced Iron Man that
kind of a thing that's sort of what you
ran into and so that's why you don't
really see the Avengers in the
traditional sense and that's why four
begins to freak out right because in
response to this they're like take four
down now again a lot of this is really
still dealing with the elements of like
the superhuman Registration Act from the
fallout of Civil War these
on those lines and that's why a lot of
the really almost all the Avengers are
underground is because if they come out
and if they make their presence known
they'll be apprehended right they'll be
thrown into the the negative zone prison
and that'll basically be it remember a
lot of things were going on during this
time that's what made the the dark range
story so cool is there were so many
moving pieces taking place right the
event the x-men were leaving the United
States and taking up residence in Utopia
again Dark Reign was a was a pretty
solid story it was pretty amazing and
it's in its way but what you basically
have here is you have won all the Dark
Avengers who are facing off against Thor
as well as Bohr who's watching the whole
thing go down and it's kind of crazy
here because in the end with Thor
temporarily incapacitated the Dark
Avengers in turn focus their power
onboard and all of them are completely
overwhelmed right they don't really have
the power to defeat Bohr because once he
starts powering up for lack of a better
word right going like super saiyan like
Super Saiyan God Super Saiyan because I
couldn't think of a better name Oh once
he gets once he gets like super powerful
he ultimately ends up channeling all
this energy with with Thor coming to the
realization it's enough power to
obliterate the entire world and for a
guy in this madden state it's not far
outside the realm of possibility that
Bohr could just snap and wipe out the
entirety of earth right just could
totally cleanse the planet that's well
within his ability to do and so the
results of this is that Thor and kind of
like this this last stand right there's
this amazing last stand you know he's
like he's like must stand and fight and
just like jumps up grabs his hammer goes
lunging at board and when he does
manages to finally take him out the
problem with this is that by literally
beating him within an inch of his life
are really killing him in the process
one he ends up fracturing and and and to
a degree
shattering Mjolnir right I mean the
whole hammer doesn't shatter in and of
itself but a huge chunk of it's missing
and that's why for those who guys who
were reading our story beta ray bill God
hunter that's why a chunk of the Hammers
missing is because literally it was it
was almost totally destroyed
killing Bork but what you also have is
you have Balder who's being brought to
this location by Loki and the reason why
is because Loki with all this going down
Loki had basically run over to Balder
and then in turn said hey man you won't
believe what's going on on earth and
boulder's like what's that and he's like
force fighting board right borders
somehow made his way back to earth Thor
is fighting him and before Thor realizes
what's going on Thor's basically told
you just killed our grandfather you just
killed dwarf Thor didn't know that right
but regardless of whether he knew it or
not it doesn't matter that at the end of
the day that he's viewed as a
only insofar is a laws it's not as
though Boris totally oblivious to what's
going on
Thor even goes as far as to plead his
case I didn't know that this was the
case I didn't know that this was bored
but the laws of Asgard are the laws of
Asgard and no one is above the law not
even their their existing ruling right
not even for the one who brought it all
back or I guess really bores the one who
runs the show but not even Thor who who
returned everything even with the
odinforce he's not above the laws and
that's what Loki asked the question is
this not though is it not the punishment
for an individual who fells a member of
Asgard a king to in turn be banished
from Asgard and the responsive
responsive Balder is yes now
Boulder's well aware of the fact that
Loki basically engineered all this in
Sohus Thor and when the questions asked
you how many final words Thor's like
know those words or for a different
person at a different point in time the
important thing here with what matters
here is ensuring that Asgard does not
fall to pieces right that the the line
of succession is kept that as far as all
the other people know that things are
going the way they're supposed to right
there like Thor committed an act that
was inherently against the rules of
Asgard and in turn he's being banished
for it right people don't need to know
the nitty-gritty of it and they sort of
don't need to know that like Thor
intends to ruin you'll bring down fire
and brimstone on Asgard itself now the
reason why this matters is because this
will go into siege right this will go
directly into the events of siege and
it'll go directly into life Asgard being
destroyed by Norman Osborn and so on
so released by the century so on and so
forth but in any event ultimately force
banished for his actions and attempts to
really swear revenge on Loki and that's
really kind of where that ends right
it's really kind where this comes to a
conclusion but one of the small little
tale tidbits to come out of this is that
Loki talking to the various as Guardians
which simply says like this place that
we're living in this Asgard in Broxton
Oklahoma this is it really isn't where
we need to be right I know of a place
that we can go to where we can hunt to
our hearts content we can do our own
thing and not really have to worry about
what's going on in the United States we
don't have to worry about the government
knocking on our door every five seconds
we can live in and be peaceful do our
own thing and that's at a place called
Latveria and it's King Victor Von Doom
who will give us all those things right
so trying to lead the Asgardians into
Liberia and under the control of Doctor
Doom again part of Norman Osborn's plan
and part of their operations as the
Cabal oh that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here - comments explained make
sure you guys to the sub button to
become part of the Rob port you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace okay I want to give a shout out to
Kyle be David Joseph Ben John H AJ Matt
and Jeff are John H lean and mean which
is an awesome name Jason see Austin s
Austin a Joey M Steven Z Austin B Adam K
and Genesis 9:6 team you remember guys
you can send me messages and I'll run
off whatever your message is at the end
of the video so long there's nothing
crazy but if you want to put a message
in there send me an email Rob at Robert
garrison calm and if you're one of these
people who get shoutouts
then I will tack it in there and yeah
they should watch you guys
[Music]
[Music]